I'm in heaven it I'm in heaven
darn gone home but it seems once again
this tables got a problem with that food
it's undercooked
after the earlier cock-up with the
undercooked chicken starter unbelievably
it happened again this is little is
vertical phoria so let me just take it
back I'm always afraid for under 200
chicken course could kill you just this
yeah on a bone slipper [ __ ] Oh Diane
come back walk mark is on the warpath
how's it possible huh
you not check any of them I mean look
you're [ __ ] pre-cooking them is it
that hard if he wants to eat raw chicken
you huh
to my horror the true scale of the
chicken scandal is only just unfolding
it's definitely raw the other bits were
ok but yeah just this one that piece
she's had one more poison no problems
the same again he also had it now wha
two more portion of clearing chicken so
they dig admission is well down this
time what's wrong with that one it's not
okay no it's the same table same taro
yeah that is it he's wrong I think the
thighs roll yeah
this is the last thing I expected from
this incredible restaurant hf mark looks
as shocked as me this is what we're
talking about quality in the consistency
I'm the one who looks at fret
something that's almost 300 yeah ah
we're supplying there's two two tables
that kind of messed it up there's only
one thank you
fingers crossed for this one this piece
is your game it's stunning it's really
really good it's it's a very big
difference from the last place I got
it's a credit to knock in the
front-of-house team that the majority
Medina seemed unaffected by the chaos
really nice really tasty he service is
amazing so really good they're really
accommodating when I said I didn't like
spicy food and stuff the part I was
really nice and mild Gulu just a sincere
apology of you above my lip to everyone
because there was a problem with the
menu in the vegetarian our particular
waiter has been absolutely wonderful
with us really attentive they take a
great interest and to our experience
here the mango tree in the end most of
my diners seem happy but for mark has
been one of the toughest nights of his
career right west restarts I know what
you're capable of
you have to read the comments - why this
freshman is in this competition and
support you've got from customers it's
phenomenal then why Downers arrives and
unfortunately they haven't had that same
experience that's where it hurts for me
come back and come back strong
good nice